france 24 y la unesco presenta
[Música]
y estamos de regreso en patrimonio en
común y antes de volver a conversar con
nuestros invitados los voy a invitar a
ver un reportaje que hizo en uno de los
sitios de túnez que son patrimonio de la
humanidad desde 1979 nuestros
corresponsales se inflama siat es el
coliseo romano del yen
con la inocencia propia de la infancia
estos niños de escuela primaria corren
en libertad
en medio de este inmenso monumento
arqueológico no conocen la importancia
de la construcción ni tampoco el motivo
de su presencia allí faisal por su parte
ha organizado una visita familiar con
sus sobrinos al coliseo de el jiam
inscrito a la lista de patrimonio
mundial de la unesco desde 1979
valencia aimme colisión busca mente
colectiva parecer con términos de orina
nablús diaria o rafa confianza una razón
bien miente en el cutis de dw que diera
mata chavales para desmejorar en ante el
abordaje de uvas no acerté al maestro
sabina taiana frena la línea
[Música]
los programas escolares en túnez no
incluyen la visita a sitios
arqueológicos en promedio durante toda
la vida educativa los tunecinos visitan
apenas dos sitios patrimoniales los
maestros de historia creen que se debe
invertir en el patrimonio arqueológico
del país para incentivar las visitas
educativas que hoy tienen un carácter
más de diversión que de transmisión
de la misma
y acogerá hasta 30.000 espectadores y su
anfiteatro que tiene tres pisos y una
altura de 35 metros es uno de los tres
sitios más visitados por los turistas
entonces
sin embargo un gran número de tunecinos
aunque han oído su nombre no saben dónde
se encuentra
es muy hermoso
rumanía
y los mejores serán si al igual que las
enfermedades de la civilidad del mal el
teatro de el jiam está en un proceso de
restauración y mantenimiento gracias a
una subvención de la embajada de los
estados unidos con la esperanza de que
sea preservado como un patrimonio
mundial para las futuras generaciones
volvemos a nuestro estudio justamente
quería preguntar el tema es uno de los
ocho patrimonios de la unesco de este
país
siete son arqueológicos uno de ellos es
este sito en el que nos encontramos que
fue víctima durante el gobierno de ben
alí de unos decretos que desclasificaron
varias hectáreas y permitieron en la
explotación inmobiliaria como afectó es
a este sitio por supuesto éste afectó el
sitio de una manera muy negativa pues
bueno todos los ricos de títulos o la
gente que quieren vivir en este sitio
magnífico como estamos por aquí entonces
están muchos intentos legales o ilegales
construir casas pues éste afecte el
sitio me parece que el lunes como muchas
veces ha mandado a habitaciones o cartas
a turnos para decir que esto no puede
pasar que tiene que conservar todo este
este sitio hacer este equilibrio entre
conservar este sitio como un sitio de
patrimonio mundial y la evolución de la
ciudad de cartago lo que está cerca de
aquí
el carisma que puede hacer la unesco
como este es un sitio protegido frente
una situación como esta bueno primero
hay que recordar que la descripción de
un sitio en la lista de patrimonio
mundial
viene de
una voluntad del país los países
presentan dossiers de proposición de
descripción de sitios en la lista
patrimonio mundial que decir que
normalmente los países
están dispuestos a poner todo lo que se
pueda poner en términos de herramientas
de
de contexto
legal institucional todo lo que le
favorece la protección de los sitios
ahora el problema que se ve en ese sitio
es un problema que se ve en muchos
sitios del mundo e incluso sitios
arqueológicos que finalmente son en un
entorno urbano finalmente estamos al
lado de la capital en las afueras de la
capital es un sitio maravilloso y
entonces el desarrollo urbano que es
absolutamente inmenso hay que recordar
que ahora más de 50% de la humanidad
vive en ciudades y eso llegará al 70%
2050 que decir que la presión al nivel
de la extensión urbana es absolutamente
inmensa en este caso lo que hay que
recordar es que la salvaguardia de un
sitio como éste pasa también por medidas
que van más allá de la conservación y de
la protección del patrimonio como cuál
sí se incluye en los planes de
desarrollo de los territorios se trata
también de lo que tiene que ver con la
vivienda de lo que ven con los
transportes de todo lo que finalmente
contribuye al
un territorio si se toma el patrimonio
solo no se puede tener la imagen global
que permite después evitar o por lo
menos corregir ese tipo de problemas
miriam veíamos en el reportaje no es
cierto el coliseo romano del dem es un
lugar muy conocido internacionalmente y
nos sorprendemos de que los niños casi
no lo conocen la historia de que en todo
el transcurso escolar 12 años de
educación van solamente dos veces tú
trabajas justamente en la transmisión
del patrimonio que lo que pasa ahí y yo
por ejemplo siempre vengo aquí a cartago
pero es verdad que la educación
pienso que hay un trabajo de
sensibilización que tenemos que hacer
también tenemos que proponer libros y no
sólo no solamente libros pero
conferencia intervista con gente que
trabaja sobre sobre el patrimonio en las
escuelas así los jóvenes van a ganar
para conocer y van a ir a visitar a los
lugares yo pienso que es más una
cuestión de hombres de voluntad también
un poco de económico de quizás padre
porque en este país en la juventud hay
una cesantía del 74% un desempleo quizás
a veces no se considera una prueba una
prioridad del centro las escuelas son
jóvenes podemos empezar con los jóvenes
y tenemos que empezar con los pequeños
pero hay que hay que sensibilizar los
profesores o si se trabaja con los
universitarios ya en el tema de
transmisión y cuál es la situación ya
con los estudiantes universitarios mucho
mejor mucho mejor ellos a ellos le
encanta venir aquí
bueno
me hacen una presión para ir de un lugar
a otro como duda nación romana cogen los
carros no son son mucho más atractivos y
más archivos y es más comprometidos
exactamente usted que falta entonces me
parece que hay un problema de entre
nosotros y el patrimonio de nuestro
patrimonio o no especialmente y cuando
hablamos de sitios arqueológicos por los
tintín tunecinos es como es otra época
otra civilización me parece por este que
hay como la gente uno visita más el caso
del museo de bardo también bueno el caso
de la tarde de barrio que hace una buena
que la gente visita más ahora el museo y
la gente va a visitar como ir y
descubrir nuestro patrimonio todo
misiones hablan de este museo de la
riqueza del museo y mucho de este museo
que conserva me parece el primero lo
segundo
en este por el mundo mundial
pienso también que hay un problema
porque por ejemplo en unos sitios como
éste
necesitamos guías gente que acompañe la
gente los pequeños más grande y eso hay
un desarrollo que hacer aquí
económicamente con el arte del
patrimonio tenemos todos que trabajar
juntos para acercarnos de algo más con
explotación más equilibrada también lo
que iba ocurriendo no en la medina de
túnez hay muchos proyectos interesantes
no dream city la juventud está haciendo
muchos proyectos con las nuevas
tecnologías
me parece que perdón aquí hay ahora es
un movimiento de jóvenes especialmente
hasta hablar de the dream city the
collective creativo de otra asociación
en se llama cartagena que son jóvenes
que hacer visitas en la medina de túnez
o también es que me parece muy
importante es un proyecto se llama
medina villa y escribir en wikipedia en
muchas lenguas en español en inglés o
francés otras idiomas sobre sitios en
túnez en general crear
artículos en we keep it entonces me
parece que hay cosas negativas pero
también hay cosas muchas positivas
después de eso ser experto con la
revolución sí sí sí porque el año 2011
récord después la revolución está la
libertad de escribir de hablar antes la
revolución tú no puedes querer una
asociación no es algo difícil es muy
difícil de crear una asociación el
desempleo son ahora dos o tres jóvenes
pueden hacer una asociación de sobre el
patrimonio o también de visitar la
medina antes de la revolución hacer
visitar la medina con gente de
extranjeros siempre hay gente policía
que viene tú quién que estás haciendo
aquí y qué estás hablando pues después
la revolución este al menos que ahora
entonces la libertad de hablar y de
activar hay muchas iniciativas privadas
otro proyecto por ejemplo de sitios de
túnez que estén postulando al patrimonio
de la unesco
túnez tiene lo que se llama una lista
indicativa que es una lista de sitios
donde el país de un potencial
a un valor universal excepcional que
podría presentar ejemplos del sur de
túnez
lo que se llama la mayoría de los
patrimonios perdona están en el noreste
parece que no existirá el resto de túnez
de la patrimonio de la unesco porque eso
eso corresponde también a una época una
manera de ver al patrimonio se ve que
finalmente cuando vemos los ocho sitios
hitos de patrimonio mundial bueno
quitamos fiscal que es un sitio natural
pero los 7 tenemos dos categorías
mayores la primera son los sitios
arqueológicos que tienen en común la
época romana más o menos que juanes por
distinto pero más o menos y también las
medianas que son los cascos antiguos
pero hay una variedad de sitios
absolutamente increíbles podemos
por ejemplo un ejemplo de que esos
sitios del sur de túnez
es un modo de ocupación de territorio
con viviendas
bonitas por ejemplo de la cultura maya
que es muy importante los bereberes la
isla de djerba que es un modo ocupación
del territorio insular un poco único hay
varios sitios pero también se puede ir
más allá hay patrimonio industrial en
este país absolutamente increíble y el
patrimonio moderno de la catedral de
sfax por ejemplo que es parte de la
reconstrucción después de la destrucción
de durante la seguridad mundial que es
un elemento arquitectónico increíble de
la época moderna por ejemplo y poca
gente conoce esa catedral hay muchos
sitios pero lo que realmente es
importante es tener el campo libre y
abierto para considerar el patrimonio de
manera muy amplia
es absolutamente esencial porque
finalmente incluso en barrios modernos
en la ciudad modernos o recientes
se trata de patrimonio porque la manera
de vivir la manera de practicar varias
expresiones culturales sociales etcétera
eso es también patrimonio y las
conexiones entre lo que es material
inmaterial es hoy más que nunca y es lo
que vamos a heredar a las nuevas
generaciones muy cortitos que nos
gustaría ustedes ver convertido en
patrimonio de la unesco en túnez
miriam que usted me puedo a mí me
encantaría que hierva fuera en la lista
del patrimonio y también sidi buzid que
me encanta muchísimo si no cuenta hierba
y tribu 6 porque hierba porque es el
país de mi papá y sidi buzid porque voy
a menudo allí y para mí es un encanto
uno uno de los dos países reales
arreglar el más lindo y el mundo para mí
y después me encantaría que los jóvenes
sean también un patrimonio y considerado
como patrimonio porque los jóvenes que
hicieron la revolución todo esto sin un
cemento caso en mi caso me gusta también
el capo bueno que eso me parece que es
una unidad geográfica tiene muchos
muchas cosas comunes naturales
arqueológicos y también y más textura
que es una ciudad
de casi 40 km de túnez y una de un
patrimonio moriscos muy interesante que
es una mezcla debut de los tres
religiones que traemos en el islam el
cristianismo y el judaísmo me parece que
puede ser un símbolo muy interesante de
este de túnez tolerante y de túnez
abierta abierta a todas las
civilizaciones y elegir una elección del
pasado al futuro muchas gracias a los
tres por habernos acompañado
lamentablemente llegamos al final pero
podríamos hablar horas de este país
maravilloso muchas gracias miriam usted
y muchas gracias karim y muchas gracias
a ustedes por habernos acompañado en
esta aventura sigan con la programación
habitual de las 24
[Aplausos]